- Try cake soup.
- What's that?
- It's a recipe I invented.
- What are you talking about?
- I'm not a chef, but it's something where
I take an entire pint
of ice cream, vanilla,
and then I get a piece of cake,
and I put it in a bowl, and I just
mash it like a lunatic until it gets
soupy, and it's called cake soup.
(funky music)
Usually, three hours before the show,
I have a cobb salad, 'cause it's got
protein, greens, everything.
- Exactly. But three hours before.
- Three hours before, never
at, like, five to showtime.
And then afterwards I
turn into a rabid animal,
and I never crave, like,
an after show salad.
So I want a tuna melt,
or pulled pork, or--
- I've seen you eat a full-on hamburger.
- Yeah, a full-on
hamburger, fried food, yeah.
So I admire artists that say, you know,
"I'm just gonna have a
little protein and go to bed.
"Who's got the tofu?"
- I do what you do, three hours before,
it's gotta be like, if
the show's at eight,
I gotta be, like, 4:35 eating.
- Exactly. Of course.
- I'll have like a half a turkey sandwich
with maybe some Popchips,
or I'll have a salad,
anything that has protein, like you said.